[Música]
son las 8:30 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y Lima continuamos en directo América
edición nocturna Les agradecemos su
sintonía vamos con los titulares de esta
jornada
el grupo de contacto para Ucrania
reunido en Alemania no logró desbloquear
el envío de los tanques hermanos
leopardos
solicita con apremio no obstante Ucrania
se mostró optimista luego de que los
aliados occidentales reiteraran su
completo apoyo a
quién Estados Unidos denominó al grupo
paramilitar ruso Wagner como
organización criminal transnacional la
agrupación cuenta con unos 50.000
mercenarios y en Ucrania luchan del lado
del kremlin de hecho fueron los
responsables de la captura de la ciudad
de soledad analizamos en esta emisión
continúa la atención en Perú donde se
han registrado fuertes enfrentamientos
entre grupos de manifestantes y la
policía en Lima las autoridades
denunciaron daños severos en la
infraestructura del centro histórico
además 120 puntos de vías nacionales
registraron bloqueos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
comenzamos en Europa porque los países
integrantes de la otan y sus aliados se
dieron cita en la localidad de Rammstein
en Alemania para discutir sobre la
guerra en Ucrania los Aliados del
Atlántico no lograron que Berlín
desbloquee el envío de tanques leopardos
al frente de guerra en el este de
Ucrania tras el encuentro el Secretario
de Defensa de Estados Unidos Lloyd
Austin reiteró que el apoyo Ucrania
sería principalmente con sistemas de
defensa antiaérea
muchos pensaron que la Cumbre de altos
cargos de defensa en la base aérea de
Rammstein en Alemania supondría un punto
de inflexión en el apoyo militar de
occidente a Ucrania pero finalmente las
esperanzas se desvanecieron ya que los
aliados no llegaron a un consenso sobre
el envío de los tanques alemanes
leopardos las fuerzas de kiev están
desesperadas por tener en sus manos este
armamento pesado antes de una esperada
nueva ofensiva rusa Berlín receloso de
una escalada bélica se muestra reticente
esto ha provocado una oleada de críticas
a Alemania por no hacer lo suficiente
Para apoyar a kiev acusaciones que niega
la impresión que a veces se tiene de que
existe una coalición unida y que
Alemania se impone en su camino es falsa
hay muchos aliados que dicen compartir
la opinión que una vez más expuse aquí
hoy
el Secretario de Defensa estadounidense
apoyó públicamente a Alemania este
viernes saben Alemania ha contribuido
mucho a esto a esta campaña son un
Aliado fiable en su discurso diario
nocturno bolodimir selensky presidente
ucraniano volvió a presionar Alemania
para que diera luz verde a la entrega de
los tanques
Sí todavía Tendremos que luchar por el
suministro de tanques modernos pero cada
día hacemos más evidente que no hay
alternativa que tomar una decisión sobre
los tanques
puede que los leopardos no lleguen a
Ucrania pero los aliados occidentales
están aumentando su apoyo con Estados
Unidos prometiendo equipos militares por
valor de 2500 millones de dólares
mientras que los países europeos como
Reino Unido o Polonia
prometido enviar nuevos paquetes de
defensa pero el kremling insiste en que
el apoyo adicional no cambiará el curso
de la guerra entre tanto en terreno
ucraniano vamos a la ciudad de cerca de
la frontera con belarus donde los
ciudadanos tomen una posible nueva
incursión por reportes de una supuesta
ofensiva tras el final del invierno y el
inicio de la primavera hasta Allí se
desplazó Catalina Gómez Ángel enviada
especial de France 24
la población en esta parte del noreste
de Ucrania especialmente en esta ciudad
de tiene razones reales para estar
preocupados como nos dicen dicen que en
las últimas semanas han venido haciendo
acopio de alimentos y de agua su
viviendas por si llegan hasta rodeados y
asediados como lo estuvieron ya al
comienzo de la invasión el año pasado
incluso otros dicen que tienen todo
listo para partir En caso de que haya
una nueva incursión Y estos temores
están fundados por los movimientos que
se han venido dando al otro lado de la
frontera en Bielorrusia en las últimas
meses y semanas Allí están estacionados
Diez mil hombres de las fuerzas rusas Y
actualmente hay ejercicios militares
entre los ejércitos de ambos países ayer
estaba mixtla capital Bielorrusia el
ministro de relaciones exteriores rusos
que se encontraba con el presidente
Alexander Luca cheducó que decía que
había cumplido todo lo había prometido a
Rusia y ayer también hablaban ambos
ministros de defensa
instituciones que monitorean muy de
cerca la guerra especialmente al
instituto de estudios de la guerra con
sede en Washington había dicho hace
meses que podrían estar planeando una
nueva incursión a finales del invierno o
comienzos de la primavera que podría ser
lejana pero que existía sin embargo en
un informe publicado en el día de hoy
Dice que esto podría haber cambiado que
esta esta idea podría estar todavía
cuajándose pero no para estas semanas
cercanas sino para una vez llegado por
ejemplo el el otoño o a finales del
verano cuando ya toda la movilización en
Rusia se hubiera cumplido y también se
hayan coordinado malas estructuras entre
ambos ejércitos sin embargo esto no
oculta el temor que hay en esta zona del
país donde la gente se está preparando y
esos temores de lo que vivieron el año
pasado vuelven a revivirse Estados
Unidos declaró al grupo paramilitar ruso
Wagner como una organización criminal
transnacional se estima que la
agrupación cuenta con unos 50.000
efectivos que actualmente están
desplegados en Ucrania y según datos de
Estados Unidos unos 40.000 habrían sido
reclutados de prisiones rusas el grupo
fue el que tomó el control de Soledad
está disputada zona y ahora se teme que
ataque bahamut y le de esta Victoria a
Rusia para analizar esta información
conectamos con layo sazz di analista de
relaciones internacionales y estudios
estratégicos de fuerzas terrestres
navales aéreas y especiales y espaciales
rusas bienvenido France 24 en principio
Qué significa Y qué implica esta
denominación de Estados Unidos
bueno es una forma para incrementar el
volumen vamos a decir de las sanciones y
Pues digamos que ya que se enfoque en la
atención internacional más de lo que
está de lo que se ven las noticias y se
habla del grupo Wagner Pues que se
aumente digamos que el enfoque pero de
manera punitiva a través de sanciones es
porque claro las sanciones
norteamericanas pues se hacen eco entre
los aliados y esto puede llevar a
sanciones y no se han hecho ya por otros
miembros no de de la alianza atlántica
de la otan y eventualmente pues puede
llevar a ser un argumento para eh poner
en el banquillo los acusados si algún
día se logra no capturando algunos de
los responsables de usados de crímenes
de guerra del grupo Wagner pues
vincularlo actividades criminales
transnacionales como parte de los cargos
de sus contras
el grupo Wagner no tiene registro legal
en ninguna parte del mundo Cómo afecta
ese vacío jurídico las posibilidades de
frenar la colaboración de gobiernos y
privados con esa organización
ese es el problema que es una
organización que oficialmente
en vista de que la ley rusa prohíbe los
grupos vamos a decirlo privado militares
o mercenarios Pues es lo que es
realmente y su líder vamos a decir
político
es amigo de Putin es uno de sus hombres
de confianza y mittributkin teniente
coronel de la inteligencia militar rusa
pues eh este lo atribuye se le atribuye
la fundación vamos a decir operativa de
ese grupo también otro miembro vamos a
decir de confianza del círculo vamos a
decir de Putin Así que cuando ellos pues
han estado combatiendo en Siria
República centroafricana Mali por
ejemplo o en el dopaz en 2014 y tras la
invasión del 2022 en Ucrania Pues claro
oficialmente
hay un algo nebuloso no el gobierno ruso
Pues los considera Putin como parte de
las fuerzas pero al mismo tiempo es como
que si no lo fueran oficialmente pero
realmente lo son porque están vinculados
en mi opinión a la inteligencia militar
rusa del Estado Mayor de las fuerzas
armadas rusas Bueno brevemente le
pregunto se tiene registro de los
activos reales y movimientos financieros
del grupo que obtiene su financiamiento
Pues en gran medida de este tráfico de
recursos naturales de los países donde
actúa
bueno esas cifras no las tengo pero como
suele ocurrir con grupos de inteligencia
apoyados por el gobierno ruso digamos
que las ramificaciones han de ser eh
variadas y profundas estoy pensando por
ejemplo en otro caso el de Víctor vote
que fue canjeado ya saben que fue de la
inteligencia militar rusa y era pues
Traficante de armas pero lo hacía no a
nivel personal en mi opinión sino por
órdenes probablemente directas de
Vladimir Putin o de la inteligencia
militar rusa Entonces por ejemplo para
que tenga una idea
frigoyen es El Financiero El Financiero
del grupo Este pero el grupo este Warner
se fundó por otro grupo que pues se
abrió otro grupo llamado el cuerpo de
ejército eslabólico que participó en
2014 en el y después en Siria y ese
grupo eslabonico cuerpo de ejército
eslabonico que es el predecesor de que
estaba basado en Hong Kong O sea que el
y recibe armas al parecer el grupo
Wagner de Corea del Norte no me
sorprendería que drones de esos kamikaze
iraníes también se han operado por este
grupo O sea que realmente es difícil
apreciar el la cantidad de dinero que
tengan pero lo último 50.000 hombres se
le atribuye que tienen de los cuales en
el cuarenta mil son convictos Diez mil
son los del núcleo duro de Los
profesionales pero usan por ejemplo el
té guión 90m que es lo más moderno el
tanque de combate más moderno que tiene
el ejército ruso O sea que tienen un
trato especial aunque se quejen que le
falta municiones
a ver en la primavera que este año una
nueva ofensiva rusa que te está hablando
ellos van a recibir tratos preferente mi
opinión en cuanto al equipo para servir
punta de cuña en avanzar en esa nueva
ofensiva claro señor muchas gracias por
su análisis y por compartirlo con
nosotros en France 24 Gracias por
invitar cambiamos de tema porque la
atención crece en Perú donde continuaron
los enfrentamientos entre la policía y
grupos de manifestantes en la llamada
toma de Lima las autoridades estiman que
los daños materiales causados hasta el
momento ascienden a 210 mil dólares y
denunciaron afectaciones severas a
infraestructuras del centro histórico
continúan las protestas en Perú las vías
a lo largo del país permanecen
bloqueadas mientras que en la capital
Lima las protestas terminaron nuevamente
en enfrentamientos entre manifestantes y
la fuerza pública yo sus propias leyes a
sus beneficios cumpliendo fielmente esa
Constitución cochina del 93 en ello
están regidos ellos lejos de escuchar
nuestra voz los gobernantes han mandado
a aniquilar a nuestros hermanos a
masacrar a nuestros pueblos entonces
hemos tenido que mandar a nuestros
hermanos a nuestros esposos a nuestros
hijos a la capital para que sean
escuchados
esos enfrentamientos marcan la peor
violencia que Perú ha visto en más de 20
años y que afecta a 18 de los 24
departamentos del país las autoridades
de la capital estiman que sufrieron
pérdidas materiales por al menos 210 mil
dólares durante la denominada toma de
Lima el 19 de enero que dejó imágenes
como estas las manifestaciones llevan
casi y por ahora el gobierno de Dina
boluarte se aferra al poder asegurando
que realizará investigaciones para
determinar las más de 50 muertes que han
dejado las protestas Mientras tanto en
cusco al menos 300 turistas se
encuentran varados por las protestas
luego de que manifestantes bloquearan el
tren que conduce a Machu Picchu eso
sería todo ahorita
estamos aquí estamos haciendo una cola
Pues están recolectando firma y están
empadronando
entre tanto los manifestantes han
asegurado que mantendrán las protestas
hasta que vean cambios aumentando la
inestabilidad en un país que ha tenido
seis presidentes en los últimos seis
años
finalizamos en Nueva York porque la casa
subastará uno de los vestidos más
famosos de la princesa Diana lo tienen
ustedes en pantalla es un vestido de
terciopelo púrpura diseñado por Víctor
edelstein que el entonces princesa de
gales usó para el retrato real junto a
su esposo Carlos en 1991 se espera una
ganancia de entre 80.000 y 120.000
dólares y hace parte de la colección de
One con la que la casa de subastas
asegura haber recolectado piezas
realmente únicas
así llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo a América aquí en France 24 a
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía y
los invitamos a continuar con nosotros
que ya llega Natalia Cabrera con toda la
información del continente americano en
aquí América feliz noche para todos
[Música]